quindici anni fa
i ricercatori erano convinti che
chiedono computer di riconoscere a mele
e pere sarebbe stato quasi impossibile
oggi e computer fanno questo e molto
altro con precisione che spesso superano
quella di esseri umani come lo fanno lo
fanno grazie all'intelligenza
artificiale
o meglio delle reti neurali che nessun
altro che modelli matematici che tentano
di simulare il nostro cervello
pensiamo ad una rete neurale come di un
neonato a cui va insegnato al mondo
tramite degli esempi
questi esempi nel caso della mia delle
pere possono essere decine di migliaia
di immagini di mele e di per questo
insieme di immagini quindi detto in
gergo dataset
cos'è un dataset come si crea un dataset
un dataset non è altro che una
collezione di immagini etichettate io
dovrò chiedere ad un essere umano di
annotare manualmente di apporre delle
etichette con scritto mela o pera su
decine di migliaia di immagini
questo processo manuale viene detto
annotazione una volta perché avrò creato
questo dataset potrà utilizzarlo per
allenare reti neurali tramite
sofisticatissime tecniche di
minimizzazione dell'errore
come avviene l'allenamento l'allenamento
avviene mostrando un'immagine alla volta
alla nostra rete neurale e chiedendole
di dirci di cosa si tratta se si tratta
di una mela o di una pera
a seconda dell'esito della risposta noi
daremo indifferente riscontro alla rete
neurale brava continua cosi oppure no
hai sbagliato
ea seconda del feedback che le daremo
lei si auto prende si aggiorna e auto
brand è importante notare in questa fase
non saremo noi a dire la rete neurale
guarda che le pere
ma non ha forma più allungata rispetto
alle mele e che le mele sono rosse ma
sarà lei in completa autonomia capire
quali sono le caratteristiche di screen
in avanti e questo è una delle cose più
potenti e dell'intelligenza artificiale
ovviamente all'inizio la rete neurale
tirerà di indovinare mano a mano che
l'allenamento procede svilupperà la
conoscenza di come sono fatte mele e
pere
ad oggi le reti neurali riescono a
riconoscere migliaia o decine di
migliaia di altre categorie oltre le
mere alle per l'est ma addirittura a
distinguere le razze canine o i melanomi
della pelle
finora però abbiamo solo parlato di
classificazione ovvero dato un'immagine
dirmi se si tratta di una mela di una
pera di un chihuahua o di un dobermann
prima di questo tipo
quando in un immagine ci sono più
oggetti come spesso accade poi nel mondo
reale
una rete neurale allenata nel con il
dataset precedente andrebbe sicuramente
in conclusione quest'immagine continua
una mela una per
le frontiere entrambe ovviamente
in questo caso a quello che si fa e
utilizzare gli object detector che non
sono altro che reti neurali più
sofisticate di quelle di prima in grado
di localizzare
nell'immagine dove sono i vari oggetti
questo è l'esempio di come potrebbe
apparire l'output di un object detector
allenato nel localizzare persone e altri
oggetti come veicoli e biciclette questo
sistema è molto più potente di quello
precedente dato che oltre a sapere cosa
è contenuto nell'immagine so anche dove
come nel caso precedente delle mele
delle pere la creazione del data 7 un
passaggio fondamentale che il problema è
che
appiccicare la semplice etichetta con
scritto persona su immagini di questo
tipo non è più sufficiente ora oltre ad
annotare i cosa devo notare il dove
manualmente e a notare il dove significa
banalmente disegnare dei rettangoli che
circoscrivono le persone come in questo
caso
ho notato io stesso mano niente questa
immagine ma mi sono presto stancato non
riuscendo neanche a concluderla perché è
veramente un processo estremamente
noioso difficile anche per le persone
più lontane
provate in oltre a pensare a questo come
il primo fotogramma di un video di un
ora
e ogni secondo di video contiene dai 25
30 frames vi lascio a voi il conto di
quanti e quante immagini da notare
manualmente ci sono in una sola ora di
video
ovviamente questo
dove potete capire è un procedimento
estremamente noioso
costoso prono ad errori e difficile e io
ovviamente non volevo passare il resto
del mio dottorato
non volevo passare anni di ricerca ad
annotare queste cose manualmente ci sono
servizi che offrono questo a pagamento
ma non volevo neanche spendere dei soldi
quindi ho cercato di trovare una
soluzione
è l'alternativa l'ho trovata nei mondi
virtuali
in particolare quello che ho fatto è
stato utilizzare uno dei videogiochi uno
dei miei videogiochi preferiti
questo
no scusate questo
questo grand theft auto 5
è un famosissimo videogioco che simula
la città una città in feb i tanti in un
mondo tridimensionale
lo scopo del gioco è scorazzare per la
città compiendo i crimini più disparati
ma questa è l'altra storia
iniettando del codice nel motore di
gioco siamo riusciti ad intercettare
diversi tipi di informazioni tra cui i
famosi rettangoli ma anche la postura e
la segmentazione oltre altre
informazioni
ovviamente tutto questo in completa
autonomia
io non ho dovuto annotare nessun
quadrato nessun rettangolo manualmente
infatti mi basterà mi è bastato chiedere
a videogiochi di dirmi dove sono le
persone che ha appena disegnato perché
il videogioco ce le ha messe sa dove
sono io devo solo chiedere
una cosa positiva dei videogiochi è
anche il fatto che sono conformi alle
normative sulla privacy
dato che nessun vero essere umano viene
coinvolto in questo processo
una caratteristica fondamentale di
questo gioco è anche il fatto che è
estremamente fotorealistico chi di voi
non è familiare con una familiarità con
questo videogioco farà di certo fatica a
distinguere il mondo reale dal mondo
simulato
quindi
questo videogioco mi ha permesso di
registrare uno dei dati più grandi mai
registrati fino adesso con più di 55
milioni di persone annotate e prima non
l'ho detto ma più dati si hanno meglio è
più dati si hanno meglio possa
addestrare una rete neurale
in realtà i dati qua sono potenzialmente
infiniti in quanto mi basterà accendere
il computer avviare il videogioco è
andare a dormire e videogioco annoterà
in maniera automatica
tutti dati che voglio
la prima della domanda che sorge
spontanea però è ma si utilizza questi
dati
sintetici nel mondo reale questa
funzione ovvero se io alleno una rete
neurale
con questi dati e poi mi generalizzare
il mondo reale
la risposta è si
fortunatamente
questi sono risultati
ottenuti con un 1 nov detector che non
ha mai visto le persone vere questa voce
detector non ha mai visto il mondo reale
solo visto il videogioco
eppure in grado di riconoscere tutte le
persone vere del video anche i bambini
e questo è
eccezionale perché in questa fase
rapporto tutta la parte della notazione
manuale che la parte di solito più
costoso
possiamo dire quindi che la rete neurale
ha imparato come sono fatte le persone
giocando da un videogioco
possiamo fare un passo oltre ora
possiamo chiedere alla rete ad una rete
neurale di stimare anche la distanza che
c'è tra queste persone a distanza tra la
camera e le persone
prima di rispondere questa domanda
facciamo un passo indietro come fanno
gli esseri umani a stimare la distanza
di oggetti che hanno di fronte a loro
lo fanno attraverso la visione
stereoscopica ovvero due immagini
leggermente diverse vengono catturate
dai nostri due occhi questa immaginano
piccole differenze
il nostro cervello le calcolo e sulla
base di questo schema la distanza
oltre la visione stereoscopica però noi
utilizziamo moltissimo anche il contesto
della scena ed è proprio per questo
motivo che veniamo ingannati da immagini
come questa
analizzando questa immagine
no il nostro cervello sta utilizzando
l'informazione che ha del mondo e in
particolare delle stanze il nostro
cervello sa che tendenzialmente le
pareti le stanze hanno le pareti
parallele a due a due hanno le finestre
rettangolari
e le mattonelle a dimensione uguale tra
loro
eppure questi pregiudizi non si
verificano per questa stanza ed è per
questo che chiediamo
in questo effetto ottico
in generale comunque
noi esseri umani utilizziamo la
dimensione relativa gli oggetti di cui
sappiamo la dimensione standard
mi spiego meglio
quando passeggiamo per strada entra
vediamo una persona alta come la lattina
con tutta probabilità si tratterà di una
persona lontana non di una persona
piccola
e questo ragionamento allo stesso
ragionamento che fanno le reti neurali
le reti neurali fanno lo stesso nostro
ragionamento persona piccola è
semplicemente più lontana di quella
grande
questa è una ricostruzione
tridimensionale ottenuta con una rete
neurale in laboratorio un fatta da noi
in grado di stimare la posizione
tridimensionale di tutte le persone che
vede quindi se l'input è solo immagine
il caso vuole che stessi lavorando a
questo progetto
durante lo scoppio dell'epidemia e io e
il mio team ci siamo detti ma questa
tecnologia potrebbe veramente essere
d'aiuto in un momento come questo
perché non utilizzarla per monitorare il
rispetto delle norme su distanziamento
sociale
quello che vedete è inter homines un
sistema di intelligenza artificiale
in grado di localizzare le persone nello
spazio tridimensionale
stimare la distanza reciproca tra ognuno
di essi e calcolare un livello di
rischio globale della scena il livello
di rischio in basso dell'interfaccia
come vedete quando le persone si
avvicinano il livello di rischio cresce
ma si allontanano il livello di rischio
cala e sistema in grado di generare
degli allarmi sonori che ricordano che
ricordano alle persone di dover
mantenere le distanze di sicurezza
il sistema può essere applicato ad
esempio nelle file dei supermercati
nelle sale di attesa
sale di attesa come quella dell'anagrafe
di modena questa è un'immagine che
risale a un anno fa circa e l'eversione
come potete vedere non si comportano
proprio bene il livello di rischio
elevatissimo infatti sappiamo tutti che
fine abbiamo fatto
quello che avete visto adesso è solo una
delle tante applicazioni che può avere
questa tecnologia
infatti questa tecnologia è alla base di
soluzioni per la guida autonoma ad
esempio davvero la necessità di sapere
dove sono le persone attorno al veicolo
soluzioni per l'interazione uomo
macchina soluzioni per la riconoscimento
di azioni per scopi di sicurezza e tante
altre
l'intelligenza artificiale non è altro
che l'ennesimo strumento a supporto
dell'umanità strumento che aumenterà
sempre di più la qualità delle nostre
vite
ed ora che avete visto come ragiona
l'intelligenza artificiale
non fatevi spaventare dalle sue
potenzialità
non fatevi spaventare da questo upgrade
perchè come avete visto una retta in e
orale non è altro che un neonato aveva
insegnato a differenza che c'è tra una
mela è una x
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]